a Cleveland area fertility clinic is
defending itself after a freezer
malfunction destroyed more than 4,000
eggs and embryos dozens of families are
suing University Hospitals for alleged
negligence the Medical Center apologized
for the March incident but it is denying
legal liability in court documents made
public this week
it says clients knew about the risks
that were involved dr. Tara Narula is
here with the escalating legal battle
doc Goodman good morning Alex since the
incident University Hospital says it's
taken significant steps to enhance
operations and equipment at its
fertility center included increases
including increased staffing and
additional training still for some
patients the changes come too late so at
that time I wasn't really thinking about
kids and I wasn't trying to have kids so
it just gave me hope
Sierra Mathews was just 19 years old
when she decided to freeze her eggs at
University Hospitals it was 2014 and she
had been diagnosed with ovarian cancer
she was one of hundreds of women who
found out in March of this year that her
eggs were destroyed when a
cryopreservation system like this one
malfunctioned I felt like I had to go
back to a really traumatizing time in my
life when I really felt like I was alone
because there was really no one my age
going through something like that
following the incident University
Hospitals CEO Tom's NT released this
video statement I can't say it any more
plainly we failed our fertility clinic
patients we are sorry I am sorry this
week in response to a lawsuit University
Hospital said women and families signed
consent forms writing in court documents
quote plaintiffs were fully advised of
the material risks benefits at
alternatives available for treatment and
thereafter voluntarily assumed and
consented to those risks our clients are
outraged Tom Merryman represents more
than 200 clients including Sierra
Mathews who lost their eggs or embryos
at the clinic you can't have it both
ways
you can't go on national TV and tell the
world that you're sorry and that you're
taking responsibility and then send an
army of lawyers into a courthouse when
people aren't paying attention and file
answers where you deny
all responsibility in a statement the
hospital says it quote filed its formal
answers to the complaints as required by
court rules and says quote our fertility
center patients trusted us for their
care and we know we need to regain their
trust it's something very tragic and
heartbreaking that like we're all going
through so I just think it's important
for me to use my voice to stand up for
the people that either can't or just
don't have the heart to yet University
Hospital says it's working to help
affected patients in a number of ways
including completing additional IVF
cycles at no cost when possible and
reimbursing storage fees was possible
part of that it's very difficult for
young women like like a 19 year old yeah
yeah I mean I think their attorney has a
very strong point here how can you save
can the hospital say we failed our
patients but then deny responsibility
for it that's right it's a very
difficult situation all around really
heartbreaking thank you for that Thank
You Tara